one
chairman you're live good afternoon
and welcome to this district planning
committee meeting on thursday the 13th
of august
2020. my name is councillor penny
channer
and i'm the vice chairman of this
committee this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect
on 4th of april in response to the kovid
19
situation now there are just a few
housekeeping rules
to run through so please bear with me
first of all
please could i ask everyone present in
this meeting
to ensure your microphone remains
unmuted
sorry it remains muted and your video
feed off when not
addressing the committee this will
reduce background noises and avoid
any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in
this meeting
you are giving your consent to be
recorded
members and officers during each item
please
use the chat function of the meeting to
indicate
if you wish to speak i will then invite
you at the appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not
be used for any other purpose
please do not use the raise hand
function as this
is not available on all member devices
when speaking and referring to the
gender papers
please can i ask you to ensure that you
reference a page or paragraph number
and lastly if members need to leave the
meeting at
any point please do make this known and
use the
chat function to signify that you need
to leave
the meeting now if i may ask officers
taking part in the meeting to introduce
themselves
starting with mr dodson
[Music]
good afternoon members paul dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance
please may i i have the next stop is
that devon
hernan i hope i pronounce your surname
correctly devon
yeah you did well done not an easy one
good afternoon members i'm devin hanna
and specialist in development
management thank you richard holmes
good afternoon members richard holmes
director of service delivery
michael johnson
johnson i'm sorry michael i think you
might be a mute
sorry uh it was the microphone good
afternoon members michael johnson
lead specialist development management
thank you
matt lee please
good afternoon members i'm matt lee lead
specialist for place here at malden
district council thank you
simon quelch simon quelch
a monitoring officer
bernard casey
good afternoon members bernie casey talk
to this afternoon's committee now
please may i ask any other officers
president president to identify
themselves or anyone else that i
officer-wise attending the meeting may
have forgotten to
ask to introduce themselves
hello georgina is that georgina butti
i'm trying to
hello yes georgina button rebel b
program lead
thank you very much is there anyone else
right oh hello catherine good afternoon
it's catherine matthews
specialist in development management
thank you and
anyone else that's not on my list and i
should have introduced
right uh that looks as though um i've
had all the officers now come forward
and
can i just thank all the officers and
members for attending and any members of
the public are listening because i
appreciate this is very hot
day today um ma'am please can i come to
you
to carry out a roll call of members to
confirm
who is in attendance thank you and for
this purpose members obviously you may
turn on
uh your microphone and
video but turn it off immediately when
you've
been seen thank you chairman members i
will take you in alphabetical order as
normal
what's that master band food sorry
present thank you councillor bassinger
i'm president verner thank you
councillor
bs field president
thank you councillor bell i'm here berna
thank you mr cancer mrs channel
um i'm present hope you can see me
i have to say uh counselor duik
that's the dueck apologies please for
council majority is working
thank you very much councillor darum
i don't believe councillor durham uh may
be coming
okay thank you councillor edwards
president
thank you ansel fleming present
master fluker president head
good afternoon bernard members present
thank you
council helm president
mr hall
president thank you councillor jarvis
austin bernard present thank you
councillor keys
councillor keith apologies apologies
he's working and couldn't get back in
time
thank you you did ring me earlier i
couldn't get in touch with you
counselor
counselor good afternoon good afternoon
bernie i'm working but i'm here
thank you councillor maze
i had heard counsellors earlier i did
indeed as well
councilman's videos
yeah president lovely thank you
councilman
councillor morris you've missed
councillor morley
council morally his apologies for
absence so counselor morris
isn't it strange how do it can't attend
it's his wallet
right thank
um here berna thank you thank you
counselor
yeah thank you burn up
schemes yes good afternoon everyone
has to stamp
she sent her apologies i believe she's
having problems with her
mother yes she's she possibly will be
dipping in and out yes caster stills
good afternoon present burner pastor
council miss white
i don't think we have council miss white
i apologize
she's like she'll be working as well
sorry i haven't been very quick to
forward these messages
oh okay lovely thank you very much that
concludes the role called german uh
thank you very much
um then i have apologies for absence now
okay okay we've received apologies for
absence from councillors
miss field boyce
oh sorry i jumped i jumped one there
sorry about that
um i meant harker yes
keys morley
morley and stamp and miss white
okay thank you very much indeed now
members i would like to move on please
to the minutes of the last meeting the
9th of july
and it's recommended the minutes of the
meeting held on the 9th of july 2020 and
their found members on pages 7 to 14
are approved as a true and accurate
record
i so move if you wish to second that
motion please turn on your video
unmute your microphone state your name
now
thank you if any member wishes to raise
any matter of accuracy
please use the chat and i did i see
councillor bamford
thank you it's on actually on page 13
the top paragraph where it says um
what i proposed on the third line it
should say
making it necessary
to undertake the proposed
extensive groundwork investigations
and insufficient information provided
with regard to the effects on the
wildlife and heritage sites
i mean i can send this separately to
berna if she requires
it because it doesn't make sense at the
moment
right well what i would say to that is
that i wasn't in the chair
at that meeting
it may well be that that wording does
need to be altered what i would like to
do is
i will get the recording checked
and we'll make sure that uh what needs
to be applied are you happy with that
not really chairman because it doesn't
make sense i was just trying to make it
make sense
it doesn't i'm not changing what it says
it's
just trying to make it make sense it
sounds as though it's okay
but i want to hear the recordings it
doesn't make sense chairman sorry
yeah thank you councillor bamford right
so if we make it make sense and we check
the recording of the meeting
do members agree that we can accept
those minutes of the meeting
agree agreed thank you very much
apologize members and chair but i can't
actually use the chat function because
it's playing up
i can't agree to me because i can't see
them
is k is councillor bamford happy with
that
council again did you when you say you
can't see them did you not have them
circulated previously have you
been able to read them at some stage
yeah i've read i always read uh with
with great detail
uh and chairman all of the documentation
that comes our way but
i i wanted to make sure that this
morning that i wanted to double check
everything
and because i can't get access to
mod.gov at the moment
i just want to record that i can't agree
the minutes because i can't
see them oh because of this okay okay
and councillor bamford are you happy if
we utilize the wording you've got
i will obviously check out on the
recording as well
how it was put over but are you happy
that we do make sense with the word in
your supplies and
could you forward the wording to the
minute taker
yes by all means chairman thank you i'll
be happy with that so bearing in mind
what councilman said it's quite
unfortunate
um that he can't agree because he can't
see them currently but everyone else i
believe
um ascends to that agreement with uh
councillor lambert's
applied wording
so we move on to gender item number four
declaration of interests
and members to disclose the existence
and nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members and members you are also
reminded that you are required to
disclose
any such interest as soon as they become
aware should the knees arise
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the check
chat function now to indicate and i will
invite you to speak
that's if i can see it at councillor
lagan
thank you chair non-pecuniary item
number 11 i've had conversations with
a vast number of persons uh objecting to
to this application
thank you council megan councillor
schemes i can see your name
answer the schemes yeah coming sorry uh
yeah i'm having trouble getting to the
agenda but
uh two items uh from memory uh
the first is uh the marsh road
application which of course i'm a member
of burnham town council
so i guess that's a non-procurement
interest
and uh bradwell b i'm a member of the
working group as well
thank you very much councillor
um yes i've got councillor fluker
and councilman yes thank you
chairman with regards to agenda item
five an interest of openness and
transparency i'm a member of the rhs and
i think that makes a difference it could
be pecuniary
um with regards to item 10 chairman i
believe i've got a perceived bias
and with regards to agenda item 11 i was
not
present for the debate i did actually
declare that
and said that i lost my internet
connection so i won't be able to
consider this application or join in the
debate so
chairman given that um
i'm going to leave the meeting now
cheers thank you very much for watching
the fluker right councillor shawnee
chancellor shauna c
thank you madam chair um the um knolls
farm item um i do know one of the
objectives
thank you not lisa excuse me is that
non-pecuniary
oh yes sorry burner yes it is and
counsellor
councillor mays
councillor maze can you hear me
counselor home could you turn your video
off
okay uh yes i can
can't hear you count for me yes i can um
can you hear me madam chairman i i can
hear you but you got broke up if you
were declaring councillor maze
uh yeah non-pecunory on item seven
and ten right thank you very much
and as i'm acquainted with um the owner
of the land and also eight and eleven as
i sit on the bradwell b
working group thank you very much
thank you councillor maurice you wish to
declare an interest
yes please chair same as councillor
lagan
i've had many conversations with uh
residents
over brad wilby thank you thank you
councillor bassinger
thank you madam chairman um items eight
and eleven i'm a member of the bradwell
b
working group non-bicunary thank you
very much
councillor vanessa valley are you
wishing to do an in
declaring interest i'm not entirely sure
madam chair
because i'm unclear about this but if
councillor skeens is declaring as a
burnhamtown councillor
then um i should do so as well but i'm
becoming more and more confused as to
what counts as a non-pecuniary interest
to be honest
but i am a burnham town councillor so
as such i should probably declare
non-pecuniary
on item five thank you thank you very
much i mean i would always recommend you
could have a
discussion um with emma holmes or
mr quelch on that matter councillor
fleming
thank you chair um item 11 um
i won't be able to vote because i lost
connection right at the end uh and the
last time this came before us thank you
i won't be able to take part in the
debate either thank you
councillor thompson please
uh thank you chairman um yeah i'm pretty
sure it's actually not an interest of
any kind but certainly
in the interests of open and openness
and transparency
i am a member of the bradwood working
group thank you
thank you very much uh councillor none
yes thank you very much chairman um well
having heard
everybody else i better declare an
interest then in
8 and 11 bradwal because i too have had
um conversations and correspondence with
uh
a variety of people over this and have a
particular interest in the heritage of
the site
non-pecuniary thank you thank you very
much
um councillor
oh i think that might be the last one
burner have i captured everyone apart
from myself
yes chairman you have chairman my my
intervene and declaring interest i'm on
the bladder working group because i
can't yes
thank you counselor i do apologize if
i'm not
no he was he's not able to use the chat
it would seem oh
okay thank you then i'll i will declare
myself um i need to declare
as you all know um non-pecuniary
interest
um um many items
that might be included in the reports
actually do relate to
some business of essex county council
where they've been a consultee
also to declare um that like some
members regarding the bradwell
application
i was not present at that meeting and
um i also did not vote therefore
obviously so
i like other members will not be able to
um
participate in the debate or vote um
at that particular item and
uh regarding knowles as well obviously
i've declared about essex county council
and areas like that that being the case
there's no more um
declarations of interest if i could then
move on
um to agenda item number five
um which is land north of marsh road
bernamon crouch s6
uh pages 15 to 72 um it's application
number
919 slash 01 208
4. before i go to the officer it does
link just
in actually with my declaration i've
just made
what i'm going to be doing members
bearing in mind i won't be able to
participate
in the bradwell um debate
um and indeed can't vote i don't think
it's right that i should remain
in the chair for that application
i also um have decided therefore the
private business section and then
when we go into public again i'm going
to remove myself from the chambers for
both
knolls farm and fradwell for the
efficiency and effective
um procedures of this meeting it is not
fair
um that i'd pop into noel's farm if i
could and also i don't want to be in a
position where i may be conflicted
therefore um members i'd like to propose
that i will take this
application marsh road but as i've just
highlighted i will be leaving the
chamber for
the items that cover um badwell
and noel's farm can i seek proposals
please uh for someone to take over that
meeting
yes chad thompson please counselor
is that second day i heard a second
arriving second second
well i heard councillor thompson come
out councillor none
did you yeah i hope counselling one for
councillor heard
i did not hear that i heard council i
heard councillor thompson
and i that's what i heard first and i
believe it's like who did you say
counselor
nun
yes uh i am content for councillor
thompson to chair this one meeting
i will draw my nomination right
counselor can i just say
um it's not for this one meeting i'm
going to be in the chair for
item five it will be for the remaining
items
are you content to still withdraw on
that basis
i can't hear you council i heard i'm
sorry great
sorry yes i am content with that thank
you right
so um mrs thompson i will be here for
item five
and then what i would like to do is i
would like to get out of the meeting
um and leave you to take uh from gender
item number six onwards
thank you chairman that would be fine
i'll be ready right so
there we go then members now i'm now
moving to agenda item number five i have
already
introduced it learned north of marsh
road burnham on crouch
in a moment i'm going to be calling on
the officer which is i believe going to
be devon herner
presenting this and members please may i
give you a reminder again
i know i might keep repeating myself but
i hope that is helpful to you
that should you wish to speak on this
item please make this known by using the
chat
function only do not raise your hand i
will then come to you in turn i do
assure you of that with the assistance
of
berna and um please can i ask you
bearing in mind
um the obviously the debate that please
make points
clear and concise and if you relate to
anything if there is a page or paragraph
number
that would be helpful so therefore
without further delay can i please go to
uh
miss herner to please present this
report
i apologize i think i was on mute thank
you chairman so this application
seeks full planning permission for 90
homes on a strategic allocation
to the north of marsh road at bernamon
crouch
it also includes the provision of public
open space landscaping and associated
infrastructure
before we move on i just wanted to
provide members with a brief verbal
update
in relation to the rams contribution
this is discussed at paragraphs
5.12.8 and five point thirteen point
twenty two and section eight of the
officer's report
the figures in these relevant paragraphs
are incorrect and should be
updated to reflect um an updated fee of
125 pound 58 per dwelling which
reflects an increase that um happened as
part of the new financial year
likewise at paragraphs 5.12.8 and
section 8
and there's a total fee that would be
required which should be a
total contribution sorry which should be
updated to be
11 302 pounds 20.
the document has also recently been
adopted and therefore it's no longer
regarded as an emerging document as
stated in the office of report
and is of substantial weight in the
determination of the application
okay so here we have the location plan
and the plan to the
bottom of your screen shows the full
extent of the strategic allocation
within the ldp
as you can see from the location plan
that the the site only relates to the
eastern
parcel of land within the site
here we have the site layout plan and
the dwellings are proposed in
seven separate parcels of
development if you like there's the a
local equipped area of play within the
uh uh southwest corner of the site i
open space to the north
we've proposed suds features two
attenuation ponds
this area of the site is actually flood
zones two and three but all of the
housing that you see is
proposed within flood zone one
there's a community orchard proposed um
down in the bottom corner of the site to
the south
east here a public right of existing
public right of way
and runs up the western boundary and
it's proposed a grampian condition
to upgrade this to hard standing to
mitigate the
more extensive use of it as a result of
the development is imposed
there's also a foul pumping station and
a substation to the west of the
entrance the layout continues the build
pattern of the
town and it's made up of grids rather
than suburban cul-de-sacs which you
would usually see with
more modern development for this
represent representation of the existing
urban grain
is considered a positive approach the
buildings have
been positioned with active frontages
with a strong building line and a
distinct street edge
and you can just see to the bottom of
the site here and there's going to be a
crossing to provide access from the site
and to the school adjacent
[Music]
so here we have the sighting of the
affordable housing
and there'll be 11 one beds which is
partly made up for bungalows and
flats over within the eastern side of
the site here
and 18 two beds and seven three beds
this is just the building height plan to
show in the majority of the properties
will be two-story with the exception of
the bungalows
and then single-story garages
and material plans show a mixture of
brick render and weatherballed
providing visual interest also
maintaining the character of burnham
this is the local equipped area play
layout
it includes five different types of play
equipment
it's located near the site access and
footpaths that would invite users from
outside the site as well if it was in
the site but it's also
not located any further than five
minutes walking distance from each of
the homes proposed
and here we move on to the um plans of
the proposed
properties this is a two bed
and three bed property here it's um so
these are two separate designs but the
same
floor plan layout another three bed
again two separate designs
and another three bed
and another four bed with two different
designs but same floor layout
another before bed these are the
bungalows provided as affordable housing
oh sorry
the two bed affordable units again two
different designs the same floor layout
three bed affordable units
and this is the flatted block
you have the bin cycle store which will
serve the flats
carports serving some of the dwellings
could garages the street scenes at the
top so you can see that the bungalows
sit within their own
character within the street scene and
then you can see the
attenuation basins within the middle two
street scenes
just to show the areas of public open
space
we have some photos of the application
site
under the surrounding area
then these this one you can see the
listed mary's church
in the background the neighbouring
school and then the street scene looking
east
so the development accords with the
minimum delivery requirements set out in
policy s2 of the local plan
and s1 of the neighborhood plan there's
been sufficient contributions towards
infrastructure services and facilities
which will be provided free conditions
in the section 106 agreement
this includes highways improvements the
junction of malden road and church road
and also school and healthcare
contributions
the development provides suitable
provision of affordable housing and
would meet the identified need for
smaller residential accommodation
it's not been found to be harmful to the
carrots and appearance of the area site
or neighbouring heritage assets
there's adequate provision for
off-street parking and mainly space
including public open space and there
would not be undue harm to the
neighboring amenity
therefore subject to the section 106 and
the proposed conditions is considered
development would be acceptable and is
recommended for approval
thank you chairman thank you uh miss
hernan
remembers under the council's public
participation scheme
we have received one submission from the
applicant
in line with the public participation
scheme i have reviewed the submission
and will now ask mr michael johnson
please
to read out the submission allocated
in the allocated time in accordance with
the scheme
mr johnson please planning officer
thank you chairman lee this is a
submission
from the applicant catherine williams of
saviles
on behalf of taylor wimpey good
afternoon members
thank you for allowing this statement to
be read in support of the application
i am the agent for the applicant taylor
wimpey as you are aware
the application seeks full planning
permission for 90
high quality residential units on
strategic
site s2k in the local plan
following extensive discussions with
officers historic
england and the town council the
proposals relate to land
in the eastern part of the allocated
site
in order to fully preserve the setting
of the grade 2 listed church
policy s6 sets out a series of criteria
for development in burnham on crouch
against which the proposals have been
assessed and considered acceptable
by your officers notably in relation to
infrastructure impact
essex county council have advised in
relation to both highways
and education matters that the
development is acceptable subject to
contributions to marsh road highway
improvements
and education provision the proposal
also include provision for the
resurfacing
of the existing right of way which runs
north south
to encourage pedestrian connectivity
with stony hills
and a new pedestrian crossing on marsh
road
through the school to improve pedestrian
safety and encourage walking
the proposals incorporate 40 affordable
housing
as required by policy h1 in a mix
supported by your housing officer
as identified by your officer the
proposals comply with policy h2
and provides 67.8 percent smaller units
overall
the proposals fully mitigate the
ecological impact of the development
and there are no objections from
statutory councils in this respect
moreover the applicants consultants have
worked closely with the environment
agency
and there are no objections in relation
to flood risk and drainage
as well as addressing all technical
consultation comments
the applicant has worked extensively
with planning and design officers
through a series of pre-application
discussions and ongoing dialogue through
the application submission
this has created a high quality design
scheme which will provide
good quality landscape areas including
public open space
a new play area and orcad for use by
future residents
as well as the existing community
overall
your officers have concluded that the
proposals are acceptable
in planning terms we are proud of the
planning application you are considering
today
and delighted to have the opportunity to
work with molden district council again
to deliver a key part of the local plan
i therefore respectfully request
that the application be approved in
accordance with your office's
recommendation
thank you thank you mr mr johns i did
let you go marginally over there the
time allowed um
for for speaking but i i thought i would
let members hear all of that submission
um which i thought was probably the best
way to do that
is there can i just ask are there are
other officers wishing to come in
at this time um was anyone else um i
know we've got mr lee here
i take it that uh if no one else is
coming in
we're happy with um obviously the
presentation there's no extra points to
add at all
this time okay members i would point out
that the there is a recommendation
to set out within the report and i will
direct your attention and it is as
follows it's
that the planning application 1901 208
slash full for the land north of marsh
road burnham
crouch be approved subject to a 106
agreement
and the conditions in section eight now
um
i'd move that if a member wishes to
second that then i will open up the
debate
um on that because i have got the name
your second it thank you councillor helm
right i have got a number of members who
wish to
to speak bernar i have got councillor
schemes morris bamford
bell swain and maize have i missed
anyone
no that's correct chairman yeah uh i've
got a hand up
oh councillor hall mustn't be able to
use the uh that's just gone up so
councillor hall as well we'll add cancer
hard to that
so otherwise that's that's everybody so
far okay so
uh councillor schemes i saw you first
well that's the order they're coming in
and that was councillor morris so
councillor schemes can you start please
with
uh yes i have serious concerns of course
as you would
possibly expect i'm concerned
most importantly about infrastructure
schools and nhs
um have expressed some reservations
uh are also equally important the ldp
we've ex we've
the local development plan we have
exceeded our allocation by far and i'm
going to return to this point in a
minute
uh also of course the badger set there's
a lot of local concern about the badger
set
uh there um the local primary school
objects they don't like
the um lay by they're concerned about
congestion on that road and it is a very
tight road
some people are saying the leap is too
small uh there's been an
at least one amber warning from the
environment agency waste management
management are worried about
distances to bins and roads and perhaps
not being highway standard
nhs properties don't seem particularly
happy conservation
officer says damage caused to
the views of saint mary's church will be
minor i disagree
and i note that in this application
there are no photographs of the views
towards saint mary's church
which i consider an admission county
highways has concerns
education department doesn't seem
particularly happy about it
uh environment agency has an objection
far bridge has concerns
natural england too gas works have
concerns
and essex wildlife i think are still
holding an objection anyway look here's
the thing
there are too many questions please
counsellous yeah i'm coming to the
question
there are too many houses here i'm not
confident that the developer
of development developers are going to
be able to provide
sufficient infrastructure uh and i and i
would need to make the point
and this is a point also which i'm
making partly on behalf of
uh councillor stamp who isn't able to be
here
she had an email from mr lee which said
as you're aware the housing figures are
a floor not a ceiling referring to the
housing figures in the
ldp however there are limitations and
issues easiest way to put it
that if an un if unallocated sites are
granted planning permission before
an application such as this one comes in
for an allocator site you can
end up in a position where the capacity
for infrastructure has already been
taken up and therefore
it could be refused yeah please i
am the local um i was gonna say i
obviously i'm being generous because
you've gone over the time already so
could i ask you to be succinct and wind
up
okay well we do have two other and
allocated sites and in
uh so i'm basically saying that i'm not
minded uh
to support this but i will say that if
and here's my question
if this is going to be approved
uh can i suggest a condition that mark
that this site needs a car park with
sufficient room for twice daily influxes
of cars dropping children off
at saint mary's with safe provision for
them to cross the road such as a
footbridge
um doubled with a zebra crossing tour
now unable to set disabled access
and if this is accepted that
we don't lose things like affordable
housing or the community orchard to get
it that's my position thank you uh as
you were quite lengthy there and as a
ward remember i've let you be a bit
lengthy
uh could i ask the officer only fair to
come and answer those points
a number of them that have been raised
actually covered off um
have been made by perhaps uh
representations and i believe they've
been covered off a large number of those
but
miss hernan can i ask you to come back
on some of those points and the
questions raised and the concerns
yeah no problem hopefully um i've got
all of those so i'll just take them in
turn so in relation to the
infrastructure and in that i include
both the nhs contributions and the
school contributions
and the the um
responses from both nhs and essex county
council in terms of
schools require uh certain contributions
monetary contributions to be able to
deliver the required infrastructure
and which the developer has agreed to
provide for the section 106
so it's considered that there will be
sufficient funds there to provide any
upgrades that are needed and in terms of
the allocations
and burn among crouch note that there is
limited infrastructure within
burnham but this is an allocated site
within the local plan
um as as um council schemes mentioned
it's not
a ceiling the it's a minimum number of
dwellings on this site which is 90
and also the fact that the
contributions will be bring forward the
required infrastructure
it wouldn't be considered reasonable for
us to object on those grounds
in terms of biodiversity and
the site is considered of limited
ecological value at the moment
um and the proposals
such as the um open space the north of
the site the orchard and the planting
within the site is considered to bring
forward
by a diversity gain and which is a
benefit which weighs in favor of the
development
the local equips area of play is um
provided to the correct sizes as
required under
our green infrastructure plan the
waste management originally the waste
management
team internally raised some concerns
about distances for um
for bins to be collected um
and travel distance from dwellings but
that's subsequently been
addressed and new plans have been
updated and they've withdrawn their
objection
uh the in terms of the heritage assets
so part of the reason that the
site now only um relates to the eastern
area rather than
the whole allocated site is to preserve
the
setting of saint mary's and burnham hall
uh just to the north of
saint mary's so with the fact that
that's being kept as
open space it's not considered that
there would be
much impacts on the setting of the
historic heritage assets
the environment agency's original
concern was to
do with flood risk um but in sort of
recent months the developer myself been
in
um conversation with them and
the flood risk assessment has been
updated so there's no longer any
concerns in that regard there's safe
refuge for
um everybody in dwellings at first floor
should there be any flood but
as i've previously advised the um all
the dwellings located in flood zone one
and there's also um safe
access emergency access to them from the
site if need be
and natural england and essex wildlife
trust
not objected to the applications of such
they've just recommended conditions to
ensure that
the developments carried out in
accordance with the mitigation schemes
uh mitigation proposals contained with
the ecological proposal
um and then i think the last point was
in relation to
parking and cancer schemes was
discussing about having a drop-off point
for the school
this was originally proposed as part of
the application but the applicant had
spoken with the local highway authority
and they'd advised that it was of
limited benefit so that was removed from
the scheme but
there's still the crossing between the
application site and the school
opposite i hope that covers it can i
quickly come back on that last point
that's a sort of
um sorry you haven't got
you haven't got your microphone on thank
you pardon i've done it something going
wrong there
miss hernan can i just ask regarding the
last point which was cancer schemes
referred to
condition can you explain where that is
covered off in the conditions i've tried
to get my conditions up to find it but
if you could just answer that point
about i think that was referring to
um the influx of traffic that regarding
the site
the last point it was the last thing
councillor scheme said
cancer screens repeat that
i was asking for a condition that put a
footbridge in there with a zebra
crossing to allow people
uh who are using wheelchairs and such
things and uh buggies
uh because i feel that's the only safe
way that you can
and with a car park inside the site the
uh as i remember the original proposal
sort of uh well there was a an ingress
problem but
i still feel that it's really important
to have a a car park in the site
which uh gives room for people to drop
off otherwise this road
is just going to be a nightmare it's
obvious to it's obvious to locals anyway
that is going to be a nightmare
and a footbridge why not a footbridge
sufficiently high for us
can you tell the answer now come back on
that please
yeah so um under condition 30. okay
thank you oh no sorry that's not the
right one yeah
i've never managed to just come up now
so 29 sorry
so that condition 29 requires that the
pedestrian crossing be provided
um as shown on the plan um
the details of which um are required
under
um condition 28 and will be um through
discussions with both ourselves and the
local highway authority
i don't think because it it should
obviously be a safe um crossing for
school children
so don't think it would be reasonable
for us to impose as part of the
condition that that would have to be a
footbridge
over the road but there should be
sufficient detail coming forward as part
of that discharge
conditions application that would ensure
that it was safe and would provide
suitable access
and i do notice on those conditions
there's quite a salient point on both
and it does say before i believe
um uh just let me get this amount about
uh
provided prior to the first occupation
of the development
yeah so that covers off on both of those
i think
that might answer your queries cancer
schemes um can i just ask who the other
ward member is please
i'm just perhaps i should know this i
know we've got burnham members but
councillor anne hall
madden chair right with councillor
morris
thank you councillor morris i did have
you down second to speak
would you give way to councillor hull
initially
as a another ward member with council of
schemes and then i will come to you
i should clarify i'm not a good member
i'm but i'm a
council morris would you be um happy to
see to that let counselor how does the
ward member speak and then i will come
to you after that
i don't know
as the ward member um that's why i was
because councillor skeen said he was and
i thought i want to find out who the
other board member is but it is yourself
so
um i do
please counselor apologize oh well
my biggest well one of my worries is the
abattoir just there
um it's quite unique to burnham and as
there's very sm
a small amount there's very few
abattoirs in the area
but being a part of the country it will
have lots of smells and noises and i'm
just concerned that
it will affect the residents and then
they will in turn
put complaints in about what you know
about
an abattoir been on their doorstep that
was one and also
will the footpath be upgraded to a
bridal way and can the bridle
can we be would we be able to ride
through the
ground that they're leaving for common
ground
right thank you council i'll ask the
officer to come in i know that there was
a condition i think it might have been
30
that would related to the footpath um
but i'm not sure if there was something
else and i'm
not not remembering correctly miss
hernan perhaps you could come in on
those points
yeah thank you chairman yes the
councillor china's correct um condition
30 in relation to the
public right-of-way and requires it to
be upgraded to
hard surfacing and this was on the basis
of the fact that it would have more
footfall
and so it isn't um
as to be used as a bridal way as such
but it is to just
um is to allow for that increase in
visitors to the footpath
and in relation to noise and smell
impacts there's nothing been raised as a
concern
from the um from our vital environmental
health colleagues
in relation to this and is noted that
there are other um of properties nearby
that aren't affected um and that there
doesn't appear to be any complaints of
to the north
of the adversary
thank you through the chair please
counsel through the chair please oh
um it can i can speak back to him yes
yes just through the chair
yes um i'm just concerned it is it's a
early morning impact and i'm not you
know from experience
people aren't used to living in the
country that that's that's always a
major problem but also would it be
possible to say that it's going to be a
bridal way through there because
burnham hasn't got any bridal ways
whatsoever
i think the officers probably asked
about miss herner come back
so in terms of the pride awards it's not
um being proposed as part of the
application
it wouldn't be reasonable for us to
impose that upon it at this stage
and and also any concerns anything
raised in relation to smells would have
to go through environmental health part
separate legislation and what i would
believe would happen to councilman
uh is um when searches are done normally
on purchase of a property so it's not a
planning matter if you're intending to
purchase then a search is normally done
and it does
perhaps reveal things in the the
locality and other issues as well
councillor morris um thank you very much
indeed for giving way to council hal the
ward member
councillor morris please hello
um thank you very much uh councillor
schemes has already pretty much covered
everything so uh
i haven't got much to say i'd like to
thank devon for her diligence
and i'd just like to inform you as chair
that i'm having problems with the chat
function
so i might need to go crash with a
question opinion
or statement occasionally thank you
thank you very much and i'm sure we'll
ask officers to look into this problem
with the chat that some members do need
to be having
uh councillor bamford i've now got
younex on the list
councillor bamford thank you chair sorry
problems with unmuting myself
um thank you chad i have two points to
raise
um one of which is to do with the leap
which i normally raise um it relates to
page 47 of the report at 5 13
3 where it refers to a management
company
to deal with the leap and other items
and then on page 61
at number eight which is talking about
the section 106 agreement
um it refers to the leap open space
footways related like lighting street
furniture signage
and all landscaping but it doesn't
mention in the section 106 agreement
anything about the management company
so although it did so in the report it
doesn't say so
in this heads of term so that's a
question
and i also want to be assured
that in the term landscaping which is
covered by
this point and covered by
the management company landscaping
includes the attenuation basin
the play equipment the pumping station
and the orchard
which isn't mentioned the public orchard
so i just want to make sure all that is
covered somewhere it's not mentioned
in the conditions at all and my other
point relates to page 29
at 5 4 16
in relation to the bungalows now they're
described at that point in the report
as a distinct characteristic within the
site
and i'm wondering if we can in any way
um
stop any um additions to those bungalows
i.e
dormers or extensions because they have
this distinctive character
on the site can we stop them being
altered in any way
so those are my two points thank you
chairman thank you very much
uh miss hello i'm going to come back now
because some of the issues that members
are raising are quite
detailed and complex i don't think it's
fair to go on to another member
i'd rather perhaps ask you to answer
those points raised by council banford
and her cousin cerns regarding the leap
um the 106 and the other matters raised
thank you chairman and in relation to
the management of the leap i just need
to check the draft
section 106 um which i don't have
immediately to hand so
i'll just need a moment to find that and
in
relation to the bungalows i think the
query was um
we could retain the existing character
um
of those so uh i can't find the section
but in part of the report it does
recommend that we
remove um committed development rights
for um in relation to
class a b and e within the site so that
would stop people
um putting extensions door windows or
out buildings within the site without
gaining plan permission from us um let's
answer that question on the bungalows
yeah but if you don't just
if you don't mind bearing me just one
second yeah no absolutely
thank you just to point out the
restriction on the development is that
condition
22. well thank you thank you very much
mr johnson you must have seen my hand
trying to scroll them
and find it
i tell devin are you happy for me to ask
another member to ask a question while
you're trying to find that what do you
think
yeah that's no problem right okay um
next on my list
oh that's my list now this is good
that's well i found it again now
counselor bell ah yes thank you madam
chairman
um you'll be relieved to know that
councillor schemes has raised most of
the points that
i intended to raise but uh just to
reiterate that you know it's it's in the
wrong place this site really
and when it was initially allocated you
know things have moved on since
then we've had significant new housing
come on on the
stream since then infrastructure
saturation but
crucially just to draw attention to
the fact this is a very very important
archaeological site
and i know there are quite strict
conditions um
in terms of archaeological um research
being done
but just uh i'd like to just reiterate
the importance
if this is approved that those are
rigidly adhered
to because it would be unthinkable to
lose
some you know part of our heritage part
of our history through this
thank you madam chairman of all
conditions as you would be aware do need
to have to be signed off at some stage
uh miss hannah have you managed to find
the 106 you were looking forward you
wished me to
go on yeah i've got that oh thank you
very much
and so the section 106 requires that um
any open space maintenance company
employed to maintain the local
local open space enters into a deep
covenant with the
council in respect of the obligations
within the 106
and then it's part of the maintenance of
the open space
which includes the landscaping it
requires
them to submit any management proposals
for all aspects of the open space so
this would include
the orchard as well um requires details
of how
the public would have access how it will
be managed and the provision of play
equipment
etc so i i think um council banff's
concerns covered off within the 106. so
there's the heads of terms but behind
that is the schedules or whatever they
call it where all the detail lays
yes as part of the application they
submit draft heads of terms and then um
we start working with them to draft the
detailed section 106 so it has a lot
more detail within the 106 which will be
the ultimate signed document thank you
council banfield i think that answers
your point on that
i think she'd like to come back chairman
just quickly is it a supplementary
council of banford
you're new to that
the condition that was referred to about
the bungalows
i think it was condition 22 was it um
that's only talking about permitted
development rights
what i was asking is if we can restrict
anything being done to the bungalows to
change them in appearance
because what that condition is saying
they can come back if they want to do
something um and they'll have planning
for to get planning permission
can we not stop them from being altered
in any way
you're talking about dormers and things
like that yes because
it would change the character mr lee it
looks like you might want to be saying
something
thank you chairman i just thought for
clarity um
obviously the only way is planning can
restrict is what would require planning
permission
we can't legally remove somebody's
ability to submit a planning application
there's no way of doing that what would
happen is
any future application would have to be
assessed in its own merits and see if
there was any harm
to the overall design but yeah there's
no way of just removing somebody's legal
right to submit an application thank you
chairman
thank you very much i think that might
have answered that counselor bamford so
thank you for that supplementary and i
think that has answered it off
councillor swain councillor swain
yes thank you madam determine some
apparently um with regard to that last
one
um i would thought covenants could be
used to
restrict changing the appearance of um
of the area of individual properties
my question of information um
i'm not clear from the um initial
diagrams
that whether there are one or two
accesses to the highways
from this development yeah i wasn't sure
whether once the south and one to the
east
um on education um
it clearly is some divergence between
the certainty that um given by the
impression of
the developer and i think the
perceptions of
other people including those in burn
about
that policy
recommended that one of the reasons uh
one of the justifications must be that
pupil demand can be accommodated
um given that their sixth county council
seem to have said that would be okay
um i think we will need to
follow up with some demand for
justification of that and how they are
going to
um meet the requirement
lastly um a point
which applies to this and i think the
rest of the agenda
i am concerned that the numbers of
members present
and voting is so small of the total
committee it does mean we have to be
extremely careful
about the decisions that we come to well
councillor swain to my knowledge we are
core eight
um i'll stand to be corrected later on i
believe
um we're core eight but and therefore we
can proceed
regarding the covenant you refer to i
will let the officer come back but i
think covenants are applied to deeds i
they're not something i believe can be
put on uh through this matter of the
process
but i'll stand to be corrected at miss
hernan please
oh mr lee then sorry i'll speak well
yeah um thank you chairman um
yeah you said it perfectly so there's
nothing really to add you it's not a
planning uh
issued in position through covenants
thank you did you wish to say anything
else that council swain referred to at
all
sorry sorry after you counsel swine no
through the chair please council swain
oh no it's just a point about accesses
i'm not clear how many
accesses are to the highways yeah we'll
get um
the case of swimmers hernan to pull up
the plans and show you thank
you can you can show your screen i think
can't you
yeah yes you can thank you
i can
it's to show the accesses councillor
swain's point
chairman i can't chat but can i confirm
it is one access
there we go yeah so there's one access
um
to the south west corner down here yeah
does that help
does that help council swain you can see
where the office is pointing to you on
the screen
yes at the bottom yes yes thank you very
much
thank you very much i think your points
have been answered
um and and i have confirmation we do
have uh we are core rate and
going forward i believe we're quarant as
well so i have had that confirmed
um last but not least i don't mean this
rudely counselor maze that's the last
name i have currently on the list
sorry madam chairman castermace has
withdrawn her question because it's
already been covered councillor hall has
spoken
but um i believe councillor thompson had
a question
oh i missed councillor thompson i do
apologize there's a method in my madness
you see getting their questions answered
one at a time because that then might
offset like we've had on several
occasions
uh members questions already answered
sorry council mrs thompson i didn't
actually see you on the chat
it got lost in the chat it's a very
quick one thank you chairman i noticed
the fire brigade recommended the use of
sprinklers
um it's almost certainly in the report
but i can't find it could someone
please confirm whether this is the case
whether it's part of the design
thank you chairman uh
right i'm not sure if that's uh i read
something some i can't remember the
informative i'm probably wrong so i
better let the officer come back
here's mr lee there was something in the
report about sprinklers
thank you yeah and
so the a65 brigade have recommended that
but that would come forward as part of
the building rigs
um stage so it'd be the next stage and
it's not required on an informative so
it is the building rigs
thank you very much thank you i think
that answers that off
right um
would like to put forward a proposal
he's put that in the
meeting chat but i know we already have
one on the
well i was going to say at the moment
there is a proposal
on the table which i made and has been
julie seconded
so that is the proposal i will have to
place first
yes but i completely understand that but
i wanted to sort of request a condition
um that i you see i'm really concerned
there's a lot of people in burnham is
that with
so many people living there plus the
school there is going to be chaos on
that tiny road
and i would like to propose that a car
park footbridge and level crossing
be a condition i think that's the only
way we're going to solve what is going
to be chaotic
well i think that might have already
been answered in the
the condition that the officer referred
to earlier
i'm not sure that condition can you
please answer that
in the in the conditions before us i did
see reference to various things
and you've already really answered
counselor schemes pointing on that
earlier but just to
re-emphasize the point think i might it
might be helpful
yeah sure so condition 28 requires um
pedestrian
dropped curves and tactile paving
immediately to the west of the access to
provide
um in front of the school and then
condition 29
um requires the detail of what can be
agreed through conditions
exactly but you'll understand it's very
hard for a local councillor to see
to see a problem coming uh
propose a solution and be told that you
can't really propose a solution
uh and it's just quite frustrating
that's all i play well i think what it
is council schemes if it's any
consolation to you
the officers have i think it's have been
a very full report
i think it's been a full consideration
of all the matters raised
i think ms hunt has been exemplary in
covering all the points that have
members
raised and answered on the platforms
and therefore i did propose and council
helm seconded at the beginning of the
debate
uh berna i'm now going to take uh a roll
call please um of the
of the voting please and could you go
through alphabetically
um to achieve that thank you very much
thank you chairman
so we start with um just bear with me
i'm having some
technical problems now so we'll start
with councillor bamford please for
before
and please uh stay clearly members for
against are
abstained
for
the passenger against
jesus oh i'm sorry
cancer for
uh castle bell against
mrs chana or
councillor edwards for
mrs fleming for
councillor head
as it's an allocated site for
helm four
the whole
that's the jarvis four
the lagan against
amaze
counselor maze against
again east council morris
definitely against
uh reluctantly for
shawnee against
the siddle for
teens we've massively exceeded our
allocation against it's unsafe
call thank you very much
thank you members that's 13 4 8 against
no abstentions so therefore members
that application has been approved we're
not going to be cheating
um when i cast my vote i heard a comment
of jesus
um i come across from a member which i
think is totally inappropriate and
incorrect
so i would just like to raise that point
i didn't hear that did would you bernie
did you did any other one he'll say that
i did very clearly
i i do counsel a passenger
um that is not appropriate within the
meeting
and i would hope that member afterwards
uh perhaps bearing in mind the offense
it
clearly has given to uh councillor
bassinger
uh perhaps feels it right within
themselves to make
an apology outside of this meeting thank
you councillor passenger
thank you madam chairman and i know they
won't but anyway okay
i'm afraid i didn't hear it but it's
often you know i'm concentrating on
other things and that but thank you
raising and i'm
hoping that that might be the answer to
your point you've raised
in that case now we're now going to have
to move on to gender item number six and
as i um
declared earlier i am now going to
actually be leaving the meeting totally
um for the reasons i gave ella i think
that is the most
sensible thing to do bearing in mind
what i stated regarding um the items
coming up
so at this point i'm going to leave the
meeting and i'm going to hand over
to councillor mrs thompson mrs thompson
will you give me time just to get out
i'm going to hang up now and can i just
one point actually thank councillor
morris
for giving way to the ward member in the
debate thank you
thank you councillor channel i can
behave myself
as long as my democratic rights are
respected
yes thank you councillors
okay um can we confirm that councillor
channel has left as she
suggested she would i stated she would
but she certainly not not with
uh just bear with me
yes it would appear she hasn't yes
thank you so we come to item six
um exclusive republican press
i'm just going to say before we move
into private session i'd like to defer
to the monitoring officer to take us
through the process for the remainder of
the meeting
so that would be mr quelch please
yes thank you very much chairman
just a reminder to members of the email
that i sent around yesterday
that the constitution requires that
if you have not heard all the debate
and received all the information you you
can't debate
or vote in the application
so if you weren't at the
if you didn't hear everything on the 9th
of july in relation to each of these two
applications there are
to be subject to private and
confidential consideration
then you wouldn't be able to vote
or debate in those two particular
applications obviously if you've
heard noel's farm and you haven't heard
bradwell or vice versa then obviously
you can
debate or vote in that particular one
where you've heard everything but
otherwise
our constitution says um that you can't
debate or vote
thank you thank you mr parks
okay i'm going to read the next bit we
now move into private session and remove
that under
section 100 over brackets 4 of the local
government act 19 yes please
yes please finish the proposal before
anyone else
speak i do not think this should be
going into pnc
i propose that we have a vote to take it
out of the industry
because the public rights
the public
if i can't manage the business of the
council because of your constant
interruptions i will close the meeting
that's warning number one
you are that is your gift i am
requesting
that a vote is taken i'm proposing that
a vote is taken
to decide whether or not this does go
into pnc
exactly
if you please let me finish this is a
proposal
we can take a vote you can have a
recorded vote if you ask for one
but please let me at least finish the
motion
thank you and would you please turn off
your video on microphone
i'm gonna begin at the beginning again
in case we've lost track
we now move into private session i move
that under section 100
graphics 4 of the local government act
1972
that the public and press be excluded
from the meeting during consideration of
the following item of business
on the grounds that it involves the
likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph 5 of
part 1
of schedule 12a to the act and this
satisfies the public interest test
apologies madam chairman could i just
ask you to
hold for a moment i'm trying to call
back in cancer schemes
fine
do i have anyone who will step into that
i'll second that counselor helm thank
you
do we have recorded votes please nice
and chair
of course oh are we all right we got
burner
uh just bear with me i need to get
cancer skins back in
we can wait um would everyone else
please
take come off the video excuse me um
chairman forgive me to to to interrupt
with your permission
could could i just say to members the
consequences
i've asked you to be quiet
then close the meeting if you must that
is your gift
it certainly is can i can i just can i
just call
please for some khan what i think
chrissy what is happening is
the chairman is calling for a vote we'll
all have an opportunity to vote on this
uh let's just go and let's get that
business done
thank you however thank you councillor i
appreciate that
and certainly i forgive the interruption
however i do wish to hear
the monitoring officer's advice because
this could have
quite severe consequences if we don't at
least be aware
of what we're doing thank you mr quilt
bullying
will not
can you give me a two and a half warning
what's the quote please members if if
you
obviously you have a choice whether you
vote in favor or against this motion
that that's the matter for you but if
you
vote against it that means the
legal advice will be open to the
developers
and that legal advice has quite
some quite strong um advice to members
in it
now by the public seeing that legal
advice that means
whatever your decision ultimately on
those applications
ultimately they will then be privy
to quite detailed and specific
information
legal advice from a very well qualified
planning barrister and that prejudice
that
may prejudice the
injuries i prejudice
well that's exactly what i said
councillor morris thank you for
repeating what i just said
please great i'll have a question for
you please mr
mr quelch oh how did you finish mr
quality
thank you i i have um counsellor thank
you may i ask
mr quelch if this uh
if this legal advice was given with a
view to it
being made public because there's
generally a difference
um may i ask whether it does make a
difference whether we're looking at
advice that was intended to be made
public or not
by the person that is a matter for the
council i mean i
i obviously am the person that
instructed mr cannon to give legal
advice
um he's given his advice uh
because it's because of the nature of
the legal advice
i've taken the view and obviously
members need to decide whether they
agree or not
that it wouldn't be in the interest of
the council for
such legal advice to be available to the
public
because it is very clear advice
about the the the manner in which
a decision was not the manner but the
decision that was made and what needs to
be done
if members wish to continue
with the decision that they've made
if we are about to be blackmailed the
public need to see it
miss councillor morris
[Applause]
you can push me yeah think you can keep
pushing me
oh no i'm not pushing you i'm standing
up for security
i'm standing up for the community
right i closed this meeting at
i've asked the member to stop doing that
uh
bye then continue with the business of
the council
i'm requesting
thank
i